my gosh i'm a terrible developer like
what did i do
why why did i do this to myself hello
everybody my name is nayan i'm the black
female engineer i provide content for
new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we're going to get into
another update for my very first
developer
job for those who don't know i work in
commerce cloud development i've been
working
there for about three months now and i
provided a
i was at first 30 days or first six
weeks now i can't remember
but um a initial review of my time there
my experience the things i noticed
things i liked don't like
and so now i'm giving more of a three
month update because you know things
change as you go
on so yeah let's get to it during that
first
month in this new role really the main
things that
were keeping me up at night were working
in sprint something i've never done
before
working with github in a team
environment i've worked with github
before but
now i was working on it to deal with
tickets and
to see if my code would be approved and
if it wasn't approved then
it getting back sent back down to me and
all of that and that was very
new to me i had i really didn't know how
github
worked in a you know manager to
developer type of context because when i
was working on my own project in the
little corner over there
it really was about me just committing
and pushing my
own changes and calling it a date there
but it works very different
when you're at work and so it was that
as well as the imposter syndrome and
also just
not being so you know
appreciative or you know so enthused
by the lack of diversity in the company
the imposter syndrome i dealt with
a lot a lot a lot um
in these first not only 30 days but also
first three months
because every single time that let's say
my code wasn't approved
i would just spiral into this
hole in my mind of oh my gosh i'm a
terrible developer like what did i do
why why did i do this to myself and just
spiraling that way and it's awful
i don't recommend it it's awful and so
i've had to
really work to not put myself
through that because other people are
dealing with the same things they're
also dealing with their code not being
not being approved right away and them
having to make changes
but they're not broadcasting it so it
makes you think like you're the only one
or you're
falling behind or something but everyone
else is like that's the process that's
why you go through code reviews and why
you
push up and your manager sees if it's
approved or not
that's why they do that because of
course changes may need to be made based
on different
businesses or based on what the major
expected of you and things like that so
like i very much focused on trying to
figure
that whole part of my job and just my
own
um like insecurities out if you follow
me on instagram at the black female
engineer
you may have seen me post about some of
these things especially like
bugs where i think i have it and i think
i know it's the problem but
then it's not the problem or when
something's working on my machine
meanwhile tom jack and harry
theirs is just not working for them and
so
just dealing with that frustration one
because
especially the whole something working
on your machine
and not on the other person's machine
that
i remember that took me forever forever
to figure out because i was so so
frustrated because i was just like okay
well like what
where am i supposed to go here then what
am i supposed to do because it's working
on mine so like i don't want to tell you
and so if you follow me on instagram you
saw me uh
talking a lot about that specifically so
yeah that was the first
month to six six to eight
week month to two months of my
job now i have gotten to
be i feel more hands-on with my work
instead of being handed things like bugs
and all to fix now actually being a part
of
projects and that's been very very
interesting and i'll actually add this
note
i very shockingly liked dealing with
bugs
because with bugs you have you know the
centers where all of the errors are
logged and things like that and
it'll tell you oh look on this line and
now you're kind of
trying to sometimes it's very very wrong
i'll say that but now you're trying to
problem solve in all of this
rather than more the front end the
regular front and dev side
where a client says oh i would like
this type of design but it's very it can
be very
broad and so you think you're really
pulling out all the stops
and then you give it to them and they're
like nah that does not
it at all so i actually ended up
liking dealing with bugs a lot more than
these open-ended
um tickets because with the bug
you kind of had a clear road to go
through
and so i will say that but yes now with
the rest of the three months being able
to now be a part of projects so my
company like i said i'm in commerce
cloud development what that means for
us is my company along with other things
will do things like
client presentations to try to get some
type
of client to work with them so let's say
i don't even know
like asos a you know e-commerce platform
an e-commerce company and trying to
have them move their own
online stores and platforms to our
platforms
so for the last like three weeks i've
been working on that side of things
being able to
build sites and apps and seeing how it
would be presented and things like that
and so that's been extremely extremely
fun
but also started out oh my gosh when i
was handed this oh my goodness i
i was not too enthused because it just i
don't know it was
seemed just like so much going from
fixing little typos
or you know fixing little lines of code
here and there
to okay make this whole demo
site make this whole xyz and i'm just
like
i'm sorry i think you came to the wrong
person so that was
very very nerve-wracking but
within like a couple days i was like i
really enjoyed it just within a couple
days because
i really do like front-end development
so being able to put those kinds of
things together putting components and
pictures and
visuals and all of that together and
showing what a site could look like
in all of this it was very very very fun
and
i got to present it if again if you
follow me on instagram you saw
that day where i um shared that i was
going to presenting to be presenting
something to my company so
i got to present it and people loved it
and
well at least i think i loved it i think
i think they loved it i hope they did
but yeah i got great feedback and so
that was just
such a rewarding experience things i've
seen that i am
really not great at and this was
something that
during coding boot camp i constantly
you know loathed and didn't like to do
and i'm now very much regretting how i
didn't push myself to do this
more and that is using debuggers and
i really wish i had pushed myself to do
this more during coding boot camp
i used it sometimes but only if like the
instructor told me to if the teacher
told me to
not really on my own volition and i am
really regretting it now because
now when i go get into certain problems
and i hit up the slat channel they're
like oh like what does the debugger say
and i'm like oh okay let me
let me pull that up so it's just i
really wish i had done that more because
now it's really
biting me and so i am going to be
working on that
specifically like really starting to
make sure that's the first thing
i do um when i get into when i have bugs
and things like that
because yes i can see all the error logs
and everything just on my own but
looking at a debugger you can really
inspect your lines of code expect
your outputs and it really can be the
difference between
a two-hour project versus a two-day one
and so i
really so if you are going either going
through coding boot camp
or learning how to code y'all install
debuggers because when you start working
yeah yeah you need to know about all
that and people will expect you to know
you know what i mean
people never really like asked if i
um knew or if i like understood or
walked me through it people were just
like oh yeah like check your debugger
and tell us what it says i'm like ah
damn like okay
okay let me let me do that so make sure
you are really pushing yourself to use
it and it'll really do you wonders
when you start working overall i do
still
love this company i still love the
people i'm working with they're very
nice
especially because i have um i have
troubles with
asking for help because of just this
insecurity that
i will be seen as incompetent and i
think
a lot of it has to do well i've always
had this even in college and everything
but i think a lot of it also has to do
with the path
in which i got to this place
and so having that extra layer of it
and so i've been really trying to push
myself to ask questions to
reach out and slash channels and every
single time i met with nothing but
kindness
and so i really need to make sure i
break out of that because you know what
if you're not
kind of that says more about them than
this about you so just remember that
when you start or while you're working
and things like that
to not um to make sure that you're
pushing yourself to ask questions
because you know what
rather like it's better to ask a dumb
question now than it is to ask a dumb
question
when you're six months in the job and
you never asked but
now they think you should know it by now
and now you're in this
whole pit of un unasked questions
and so make sure you're asking those
questions i say dumb questions they're
not doing questions they're not dumb
questions if you have them
they're not a dumb question so make sure
you just do keep that in mind whether
you are including boot camp whether you
are in school or
in your new job or any of the like
make sure you are keeping that in mind
and i'll make sure to keep that in mind
and so i've definitely moved from
the i've definitely moved from
constantly being
on edge constantly being scared
and nervous and just in my head
for the first you know six weeks to now
being pumped you know what i mean to now
being excited and
finally getting that fulfillment of
everything because i've put away
all of well maybe not all but i've put
away the
bad stuff like the imposter syndrome and
the freaking out and me entering my own
black holes in my mind and everything
and now
have just taken these new challenges as
they come
and taking them as opportunities
opportunities to learn which they
are they are opportunities to learn and
so that has
done wonders for how happy i am day by
day
so i hope you enjoyed this video let me
know if you have any questions about
the first job experience or anything i'd
love to have a chat with you about it
you can also dm me i answer my dms
so dm me if you'd like more of a
conversation but no
i hope you enjoyed this and i'll talk to
you all later
bye